my name is Saul Perlmutter and I'm a
professor of physics at the University
of California Berkeley and that just
gave a session where I described the the
work that we've been doing to the
participants here when I was interested
particularly in the fact that we're at a
unusual moment in history where we're
getting at some very deep fundamental
questions about how the world is put
together how the universe works and but
um it's a what is also rare times when
you can actually understand how the
measurements led us to this conclusion
how we measure the history of the
expansion of the universe and discovery
that actually universe is doing some
very strange it's a it's speeding up in
Saskatchewan when we would have thought
gravity when its tone it down sort of
dominance so what I was trying to get
across a little bit was a sense in which
there are some very cheap things that
are easily understood and explain but I
also want to convey a little bit about
this sense that we are still at a time
in history where we hone in very basic
things but how the world works and I at
the end was asked that question about
the houses made to the things we're
doing around us around here today and I
said what's been surprising is how when
you learn something very deep about how
the world works it tends to make you
more capable and powerful in the world
and more able to address problems in the
world and we have no idea why that works
we've no idea why for example Einstein's
theory of general relativity which one
the most abstract a fundamental theories
that you can imagine this instead
nothing to do with the world around us
and yet we would not be able to use GPS
you wouldn't be able to land airplanes
with the christening satellites yeah
without knowing my stance they were
trivial cheaply and so I was a better
one of the things that were very excited
about yes question that we have a chance
to keep moving ahead as a civilization
and learning about the world of the
living and it makes you optimistic about
the Kingsley right bill to do in the
world at the same time I also pointed
out that this project was one that we
thought were they take us I was really
very difficult we take us three years to
do in the end it took us 10 years to do
and yet none of us participants about to
restrain
it was a very good use of time but what
it doesn't remind us is that some of the
questions in the world those are some
causes in the world are difficult enough
problems that you could attend a number
of years working on them you won't get
it right the first try or the second
charger third try and that when we
address the problems that girl
discussing here at Davos you really have
to come at them with slightly longer
range picture but we're going to keep
working on them until we get them right
and then that you're they're great
problems in basically you can't be
frustrated if after a year or so you
haven't solved those problems so that
was a part of what was that going on
today at the session